[Música]
excelente muy buenas tardes y bueno
nomas quiero disfrutar este momento
porque hace 10 años soñé con estar aquí
no sé cómo se logró eso tal parece que
todo lo que deseo bueno o malo se da y
hay alguna yo creo que hay alguna
fórmula no sé sea una cuestión divina o
no sé que sea pero el chiste es que es
importante este momento para mí
a la edad de 7 años yo vi una película
que se llama un día de vida de emilio el
indio fernández y trata de la historia
de un general en la revolución que
deponer sus armas pacíficamente ante el
nuevo gobierno que traiciona a su pueblo
y a su gente todo lo que tiene que hacer
este general básicamente para salvar su
vida es decir saben que lo siento me
equivoqué ustedes pueden imaginarse mi
prédica mente en el cual este ser humano
se encuentra la posición en la cual lo
han puesto ustedes qué harían tú qué
harías o tú qué harías yo que haría
recuerdo esa misma esa misma tarde mi
padre al cumplir 18 años me dice hijo
siéntate tenemos que platicar a mí me
abandono el miedo y el terror ingresé a
un plano existencial en el cual puedes
pude sentir a los muertos su sentir que
es nada en especial y ahí estaba yo
deshecho verdad intrigado por esto que
vas a hacer de tu vida hijo no sé no
tengo la menor idea que voy a hacer de
mi vida y de repente recordé esta
historia y lo que me hizo sentir lo que
me hizo sentir fue como una daga que
abro mi corazón y rompió en pedazos mi
corazón
quiero contar historias quiero ser
director de cine papá quiero contar
historias hacer sentir a la gente lo que
esa historia me hizo sentir a mí quiero
expresar todo el poder que tengo dentro
de mí
a mi padre se le borró la sonrisa de sus
labios y el brillo de sus ojos cayó al
infinito pude ver la decepción en sus
palabras cuando me dice entre los
dientes artista
saca de su cartera dos billetes uno de a
cien y el otro de a veinte si escoges
este billete jamás nunca nada te
faltarán siempre estarás bien con una
condición
qué vas a ser siempre lo que se te diga
estudiarás esta carrera te casarás a
esta edad
tendrás este número de hijos que ves
tiradas platicar hazte pintar así el
cabello te decidas como los demás
los sábados irás todas las noches a
cenar con tus suegros y los domingos a
misa a rezar y así hasta el infinito
pero de este lado hay un billete de a 20
si lo tomas hijo mío ahí está la puerta
escoge el camino que más te convenga
ustedes que habían y de repente recuerdo
la historia del general y estoy en esa
posición entre la vida y la muerte
sin pensarlo como un impulso impulsivo
como soy agarro el billete de 20 y corre
entre mis manos para derribar la puerta
y voy corriendo en la carrera y escucho
a mi padre gritar por atrás y dijo hijo
de 20 regresa hay un mundo muy cruel y
despiadado aquí afuera que mata a sus
artistas de hambre
regresa por favor aún recuerdo esas
palabras pero yo no regrese no podía
hacerlo sentía el viento golpeando mi
rostro mientras que yo seguía de frente
sin parar
obviamente dos años viajando en toda la
república entre estados pueblos y
ranchos y fue ahí afuera de san miguel
de allende donde yo encontré una
historia que querían con que quería
contar sin buscarla y esta historia
trata de los migrantes de jóvenes como
ustedes que se van a trabajar en eeuu y
que dejan a sus viejos al borde de la
muerte
viviendo en estas rancherías analfabetas
un locutor todos los días por medio de
la radio lee las cartas a esta gente
dándoles un poquito de esperanza y en
esas cartas venían billetes de a 5 y de
se me hizo una maravillosa historia qué
increíble historia si yo puedo lograr
realizarla yo con esta historia quiero
iniciar mi carrera 5 ahora como le voy a
hacer no sé de hacer películas
nada
nos escribirla y me escribo voy a hacer
el examen de admisión y una escuela de
mexico de cine donde 15 mil aspirantes
hacían el examen y solamente aceptaban
20 el número 20 sale por todos lados en
mi vida qué posibilidades tengo yo con
un coeficiente intelectual de 1.0 de
poder aprobar y estar dentro de los
estudiantes ninguno más y nunca más sin
embargo sigue seguí las reglas
me acople a ellas hice el examen de
admisión pero ya estaba dicho nunca lo
aprobé tuve que pensar en una manera más
diestra y es cuando descubrí en mí cómo
había llegado a ese punto después de dos
años de viajar por toda la república
después de haber trabajado de mesero
haciendo ladrillos en zacatecas
vendiendo vajillas de peltre en los
pueblos de jalisco o sea yo me la flete
completamente todas
la audacia había llegado allí por medio
de la audacia que es la audacia que es
ser audaz
la audacia es una parte de la
inteligencia que te obliga a actuar es
un detonador esa
no pide mi permiso ni perdón es agresivo
la audacia se mueve por sí sola
simplemente necesitas un plan donde no
existen ni reglas ni normas simplemente
obtener lo que tú quieres esa es la
audacia
por qué digo esto
porque todavía entonces yo sentía muy
fresco en mi corazón las palabras de mi
padre que me seguían por todos lados y
ahí estaba yo fracasado no entonces yo
no podía regresar yo tenía dos opciones
o regresar y tomar la oferta de 20 o
seguir adelante con el billete de a 20
así es de que una vez más me la fete y
lo que hice fue pensar y romper todas
las reglas que se me habían impuesto
todas estas reglas absurdas que para mí
es bien mal para mis propósitos no me
servían no tenían ningún fin y lo que
hice fue seguir al director de la
escuela por cuatro jueves
y me di cuenta que iba a un bar a la
zona rosa que se llama el carrusel y ahí
nos hicimos grandes amigos y un día me
preguntaba yo tú qué haces pues yo
quisiera estudiar no sé todavía no me
interesa nada yo soy director de una
escuela por si te interesa y qué haces
hacen estudiamos para cine es eso
después de dos años y medio que estuve
ahí le confesé la verdad y en premio en
lugar de delatar y volverme a enviar el
calabozo como mi padre me dio una beca a
estudiar en los ángeles
ahí yo aprendí de nuevo a rehacer
películas ahora ya tenía el libreto
ahora ya tenga el conocimiento pero no
tenga la pinchi lana
pero está bien no es ningún problema el
dinero no es ningún problema en verdad
donde si saben dónde buscarlo y cómo
buscarlo entonces lo que yo hice es
aprender de todo este camino y como
jugué y manipular al director de la
escuela para poderme no solamente ver y
meterme a la escuela sino beccar
y lo que hice fue
o seguir gente de dinero hombres
poderosos influyentes pero como le
vendes a un hombre poderoso influyente
un proyecto tan pequeño
resulta ser que los hombres poderosos
también tienen este lado de sentimiento
y una vez que yo estaba sentado ahí y si
en la primera oportunidad que me dieron
todo el mundo me decía que no y me
cerraron las puertas como por dos o tres
años de repente conseguí un dinerito y
cuando estaba la guerra aquí en ciudad
juárez en su más marca en su máxima
expresión
nosotros nos subimos para filmar una
película apenas con 20 mil dólares
los indígenas tarahumaras que tenían
razón nos rodearon la cabaña el set
principal y estaban amenazándola con
quemarla con machetes la tenían rodeada
y a mí me costaba 1.500 dólares por día
a cada producción
entonces se me acabó el dinero y ahí
tenía todos los actores a todo el staff
ya nomás comíamos burritos todas las
tardes sino más dos por persona la gente
empezó a irse entonces me entró una
desesperación un miedo que pude
controlar
me sentía impotente y de nuevo volví a
la vida porque volvía a recordar
volví a buscar a la gente de dinero y
todo el mundo me decía que no hasta que
un día un amigo mío sergio cavada cuando
yo ya tenía 15 días y no tenía dinero ni
como regresarme para filmar esta hermosa
historia me dice es mi cumpleaños 20 de
esa película por la paz
y que voy a esa fiesta y ahí me
encuentro con gente de dinero
y que empiezo a estirarle es el rollo
todo mundo y cuánto voy a ganar le digo
no no vas a ganar absolutamente nada no
hay retorno en esto entonces qué mala
inversión es hasta que me topé con el
último mi última esperanza era arturo
muñoz
y es muy brillante y muy inteligente la
única pregunta que me hizo es me puede
hacer sentir
ni siquiera me pregunto cuánto necesito
cuánto va a costar
hazme sentir de recuerdo y de pronto
recuerdo esa conversación que yo tuve
con mi padre que la puse en el libreto y
se la empiezo a describir y él empieza a
llorar
algo le hizo clic cuánto necesitas para
filmar tu película 200.000
vete a la sierra y termina la cuando
suba la sierra si empezamos a filmar y
en eso la guerra entre los narcos y el
ejército estaba en su apogeo y teníamos
que cortar cada tres minutos acción
los soldados nos vigilaban y nos
protegían y nos cuidaban entonces que
cada uno de ellos cada uno de ellos
estaba asignado casi a cada uno de los
artistas porque mataron a varias
personas en el hotel donde estábamos
hospedando en ese trayecto
cuando terminamos la película nadie la
quiso comprar
y de nuevo me volvía a sentir de esta
manera que tengo que hacer para volver a
salir adelante como me puedo de nuevo
desarrollar una estrategia audaz para
porque esta película puede salir y no
salía después de un año y medio yo
dormía en la cajuela de un carro aquí
afuera en soriana
y fueron los días más interesantes de mi
vida porque algo sucedió ahí magia
y de repente una persona que ve la
película en un festival quién sabe dónde
dice la quiero comprar
y nos aventamos un viaje maravilloso en
donde básicamente yo entendí muy bien
cuál es el objetivo de hacer películas y
el objetivo de conseguir ese dinero de
la gente que tiene los recursos
a la gente de recursos le interesa
invertir en el arte no más que no
encuentra con quien por medio de
fundaciones o asociaciones la gente va y
les pide dinero y hay algunas personas a
los mejores como yo lo hice al principio
ustedes que van muy bien preparados con
un montón de números diciéndole más o
menos cuánto van a ganar pero en el cine
no hay retorno no hay ganancias no las
hay y estos hombres no saben cómo
llegarle a ese hombre como hacerle que
invierte en tu proyecto equis cantidad
de dinero para que tú lo puedas realizar
estos hombres están siempre interesados
en el arte y andan buscando siempre un
artista que sea un portal que los lleve
al otro lado porque saben ustedes que el
arte es lo un el último recurso el
último rincón de la humanidad donde aún
podemos desplazarnos y expresar lo que
sentimos el artista es uno de los entes
más poderosos y más importantes aunque
la percepción que tenga todo mundo es
básicamente de que se muere de hambre
eres artista fa te vas a morir de hambre
no hay ningún respeto para nosotros
ningún respeto para nosotros pero lo que
sí hay si es este reconocimiento que
saben que el arte los va a llevar en la
época de los medios y los los lo peor de
la época del renacimiento los medici
invierte en el leonardo en da vinci
sí precisamente para que carguen su
nombre para que para que limpien su
conciencia y esto mismo hacen estos
hombres después de tener fábricas que
destruyen nuestra salud nuestro clima y
nuestro ambiente
ellos están deseosos básicas
debe encontrar una persona que los lleve
de la mano hacia otro lugar
y en eso me convertí en un portal hacia
otra dimensión donde yo no voy a
ingresar a tu a tu realidad y no me
hagas hacer números y me pongas en un
contexto de administración yo te voy a
invitar a mi realidad y sacarlo de ahí
y de repente me doy cuenta que también
son artistas que quisieron escribir una
película que quisieron pintar que
quisieron hacer algo verdaderamente que
exprese su corazón y todo lo bello que
llevan por dentro como a pelas a eso
como los hace sentir como los descubres
y como les arranca se estampa majestuosa
de arrogancia y de poder y los bajas a
un contexto donde dos seres humanos
están hablando sobre algo hermoso la
belleza y el poder de sentir y hacer
sentir eso es súper interesante lidiar
con estos hombres que son brillantes y
que han construido un imperio o sea no
es cosa fácil también hay que ir muy
bien preparado pero la idea es que
ustedes no jueguen el juego de ellos la
idea es que ellos vean ustedes la
posibilidad de crear algo interesante y
ustedes van a obtener un dinero
para invertir en su obra y eso es lo que
hago investigo a la persona
veo quién es mi próximo target y escribo
la historia basado en él
en tu caso
cuando se estrena la película de cartas
el n tiene un éxito sensacional no es
porque sea una gran película
yo no soy un gran director estoy
aprendiendo soy bastante mediocre es la
verdad pero sí sé cómo obtener los
recursos y cómo sacar un proyecto
adelante por medio de un juego de
ajedrez en donde la audacia lo es
entonces después de tener un éxito
rotundo en nueva york si uno de los
padres de los inversionistas principales
de la obra después de no hablarse por
más de 20 años estar distanciados y
peleados ellos entre familia entre
sangre el hombre el papá de mi amigo
inversionista abel ve en la marquesina
en hollywood boulevard el nombre de la
película
en el cine y la b
y le llama a su hijo después de 20 años
y le dice por primera vez estoy
orgulloso de ti
eso
más que cualquier ganancia más que
cualquier cosa que pudo haber obtenido
otro carro un ferrari un rolex un
departamento un amante lo que sea era
nada en comparación con haber saldado
esa emoción
qué importante fue esa película porque a
todo el mundo no sanó y recuerdan a mi
padre que nunca creyó en mí recuerdan a
mi padre las palabras que me dijo allá
allá afuera y un mundo cruel y
despiadado que mata a sus artistas de
hambre
pues cuando llega a su departamento veo
que hay miles de recortes de películas
de la película entrevistas reportajes y
mi padre abre la puerta a té nuevamente
así como que no queriendo
enfrentarme pero yo nomás iba a redimir
me yo nomás iba a pedirle perdón por
haberle hecho caso y aquí estoy padre
mío nomás para demostrarte que todo está
bien gracias
mi padre muere cuatro días después ya
enfermo de cáncer nunca pudo ver la
película y eso es algo que todavía
traigo aquí muy metido adentro esa
película tuvo éxito por una sola razón
además de conectar con la gente había
una guerra tremenda en todo méxico en el
cual no había nada hermoso ni nada bello
que expresar había una guerra mortal en
méxico en el cual todo era caos
destrucción y muerte y de repente sale
esta peliculita con amor
con esperanza y de repente todo méxico
la abraza y la película empieza a
funcionar y termina en 10 idiomas en 20
países porque todo el mundo está
cayéndose y necesitaban de este proyecto
que es lo que hace un buen proyecto
básicamente circular dentro de la
sociedad tiene que haber tiene que ser
la coyuntura que se da política y
socialmente y esta película encontró
encontró esa ranura y se pudo meter en
un momento donde había desesperanza y
muerte y todo el mundo vio esta película
para poder
respirar
recuerdan al general
en general prefiero la muerte
pero no pidió perdón
la astucia es algo es un recurso es una
herramienta en nuestras vidas
extraordinarias más que ser inteligente
porque el inteligente siempre quiere que
lo que se le tome en cuenta como
inteligente siempre quiere que se le
adore como inteligente y hace cosas
inteligentes pero el audaz
es el que logra las cosas el audaz
trabaja tranquilo y escondido y sin
hacer ruido
a diferencia del inteligente que todo lo
quiere demostrar
de ahí en adelante yo yo yo creo mis
proyectos tranquilos sin llenarlos de
energía de mala energía
entonces la audacia es lo que nos mueve
a nosotros la audacia es lo que nos hace
conseguir los recursos para prosperar en
esta industria que cada vez está más
cerrada y cada vez es más competida
yo como le repito me he convertido en un
portal no tengo vergüenza
ni tampoco me importa el qué dirán y el
notado que el común denominador entre
mis compañeros que han tenido pláticas
aquí con ustedes ha sido básicamente eso
el sentimiento de culpa
el evitar echarle la culpa a alguien más
el ser dueños de su propio destino y
aunque todo eso sea muy trillado a la
gente hay que volverse lo a repetir
porque es muy difícil hacer eso para mí
lo más complicado en el mundo es dejar
de pensar lo que la gente piensa de mí
una vez que se liberan ustedes de esa de
ese trauma de ese miedo que paraliza y
que no los deja hacer nada ustedes no
van a tener todo el horizonte amplio
para poder crear
eso es lo más difícil que hay en el
mundo pero al final yo lo pude lograr sí
y he logrado también una comodidad una
tranquilidad conmigo pero sobre todo
estoy libre de no echarle la culpa a
nadie por mis victorias y fracasos no le
debo perdón a nadie si nadie me de un
perdón a mí
así es que muchas gracias por todo y
gracias por escucharme